there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people so when they
needed us we could fight the battles
that they never could
[Music]
welcome back everyone its trailer week
that's right there's gonna be a whole
bunch of trailers coming up in the next
week including the Black Widow trailer
so I'll break down what that is when
everything is happening and there's a
special Marvel phase for Comic Con panel
at Brazil Comic Con where Kevin Feige is
personally going to unveil more details
about the future of the MCU that he has
not revealed already of course I'll be
covering all that stuff in my videos
next week too so be sure to subscribe to
get everything
we're still doing that infinity Saga a
giant box set giveaway to I will be
naming the first giveaway winner for
that next week all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
biggest theory about what the black
widow post credit scene is going to be
the reason why all this stuff is
happening is because Brazil Comic Con is
next weekend in the studio's typically
use that as their big convention at the
end of the year to unveil trailers for
all the big movies next year as per
usual Marvel is doing a big panel there
in addition to DC but this year Kevin
Feige is going personally to
quote-unquote unveil future details
about the MCU that he is not already but
we also know what's going on with the
black widow trailer so we'll break that
down first then I'll talk about the
other stuff that Kevin Feige is going to
reveal this is just the d23 footage so
keep in mind that it'll be much more
complete as a trailer than just a couple
scenes strung together but this is the
footage that they've showed up
previously it started with a montage of
Black Widow in the other Marvel movies
so far doing voice over saying I used to
have nothing then I got this job this
family I was better because of it I've
made mistakes I can't go back and then
the Marvel Studios logo all that
dialogue was just borrowed from her
Avengers end game dialogue before they
went into the quantum realm and she
sacrificed herself then text flashes on
the screen saying Budapest finally
revealing part of what's happened in
Budapest there are a couple different
times that Black Widow has been involved
in Budapest 1 in the past when she ran
into Hawkeye for the first time and then
one closer to present-day that we'll see
during the course of the Black Widow
movie then there's a scene of Black
Widow walking into an old apartment
building with her gun drawn looking for
yelling a Bulova in one of the apartment
rooms she hears her say from the other
side of the wall I know you're out there
that she replies I know you know she
turns the corner with her gun drawn
still being very cautious in yelling a
biloba is standing there and says is
that what we are
they tell each other to put their guns
down neither one does this is really
tense beat then they steal each other's
guns using the exact same move at the
exact same time because they both been
trained in the red-room program so they
know all the same moves this happens a
couple times with both of them stealing
each other's guns before they start
their big fist fight so then they start
brawling as you see during this footage
even though they're very consistent with
Black Widows fighting style across the
Marvel movies they have the John wick
fight coordinator so it just extra down
and dirty it feels a lot like Bucky
versus Captain America in Winter Soldier
but with Black Widows fighting style
they both wind up knocking each other
out they pass out on the ground they cut
to a scene of them pouring drinks for
each other in black widow says good to
see you too says because they refer to
each other like sisters because they
came up in the red room together then
she says you just had to come to
Budapest didn't you then they cut to a
montage of a bunch of different scenes
clipped together there's one with Black
Widow running across this beautiful
mountain range by herself then there's
another scene with a bunch of other
Black Widow Red Room agents pointing
guns at her while she's on the rooftop
of a building then there's a separate
motorcycle chase that looks like it's
right out of a Mission Impossible movie
finally there's the scene of Black Widow
in a car that gets smashed into a bridge
in the middle of the night this scene
here it gets flipped over the cars
burning but she looks out and taskmaster
is coming for her she shoots but he
pulls out his shield to stop the bullets
the fighting begins they have a very
similar fighting style and because of
taskmasters moves he catches on to her
moves even quicker and learns to
anticipate and beat her after a few more
moves they both kneel down and then look
up at each other in the same position as
if they were mirrored so this is
basically him just using that ability
this is the concept art and then this is
the footage that we've seen of him on
set so far obviously this will be tuned
up quite a bit with special effects but
like I said the footage they show up in
the actual trailer next week will be way
way bigger what I'm anticipating is is
that it'll probably be Tuesday morning
at the ass crack of dawn on Good Morning
America which is typically where they
released their Marvel trailers this week
around Thanksgiving if it's not
something special like last year for
Avengers endgame they released it on a
Friday that's not gonna happen this year
for those that are still a little
confused about how the Black Widow movie
can exist when Natasha sacrificed
herself during Avengers end
the whole concept of this movie is that
it takes place during the past but there
will be some moments that take place in
present day because it is a moral phase
for movie and obviously the whole idea
is to push the timeline forward
most of the stuff that's happening in
the past is a combination of flashbacks
to her childhood growing up in the Red
Room we have a couple deleted scenes
from Avengers age of Ultron that detail
that still expand upon I'll play those
clips in a second but the present day of
the movie will mostly take place between
the events of Captain America Civil War
in Avengers endgame but because a big
part of the Black Widow movie is her
trying to save Jelena Bulova from the
Red Room the same way that Hawkeye gave
her an offer for a better way to live
people are now theorizing that the
blonde hair in infinity war has
something to do with her time with
Jelena biloba now I do think that Jelena
Bulova will be important to Marvel phase
4 in any Thunder Bulls or Dark Avengers
project that they do in the future but
as wide open a theorycrafting we'll talk
about it more when they released the
actual trailer I'm also really really
excited to see Alexei szostak Hoff
played by David Harbor he's the Russian
version of Captain America called Red
Guardian you can kind of see his suit
here on the poster he has a full-on
Russian red version of a Captain America
suit with a shield to match here those
deleted scenes with Black Widow from
Avengers age of Ultron for her backstory
[Music]
again you'll break them only the
breakable ones you're made of marble
will celebrate after the graduation
ceremony what if I fail most of all that
stuff came from joss whedon they made
him cut that before the actual movie
came out but getting into the big Marvel
comic con panel the Kevin Feige is doing
next week the reason why this is a
special big deal is because normally he
just sends a pre-recorded greeting
saying thank you for coming to the
convention here's a trailer watch some
footage the only reason he would go in
person is if he's going to be revealing
a lot of extra new details that he
hasn't revealed already they've already
revealed all of the Marvel phase 4 movie
dates and all the TV shows that are
gonna be on Disney plus the extras that
we're still wondering about are all the
big phase 5 dates starting in 2022 I did
a video a little while ago about
Avengers 5 in the five new mystery movie
dates that they've revealed and what
those are probably going to be we know
Black Panther 2 is gonna be May 20-22
right now there's a rumor a lot of
people believe that Fantastic Four is
gonna be the next big movie after Black
Panther so we're all kind of waiting for
an official Fantastic Four announcement
I'm not expecting him to reveal that but
that would be amazing there's also a
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 which
based on their production start date is
probably gonna be February 2023 they've
already told us they're gonna do Captain
Marvel - he might reveal when that's
going to happen we know spider-man 4 is
going to happen but I don't think
they're gonna talk about that until
after spider-man 3 comes out then
there's the blade movie we still don't
know when that's coming out he could
reveal when that's going to be so aside
from that he'll probably show off some
different Black Widow footage that's not
going to be in the trailer that we'll
watch next week and maybe some early
Eternals footage because they're deep
into shooting that right now so they
probably have something to show off
there's been all kinds of rumors about
post-credit scenes for Thunderbolts and
future Dark Avengers stuff through
general Ross I know everyone's wondering
if he might become a version of Red Hook
eventually in the movies the cool thing
about William Hurt is that the only
reason why he took the job on the first
Incredible Hulk film and signed the
contract and came back for all these
films is because he is a huge fan of the
comics and all those family of
characters so I don't think he would
sign up to be Thunderbolt Ross without
the idea that someday he might get to
play a version of Red Hulk but you have
to remember when he signed that original
contract that was back during Incredible
Hulk era Edward Norton told us that they
were actually supposed to be three
Incredible Hulk films and the leader was
supposed to be the villain of the sequel
for those of you wondering what happened
to the leader after that movie
[Music]
so whatever happens at the Marvel comic
con panel next week I will totally do a
breakdown video for that in addition to
the black widow trailer video there's a
couple other DC trailers that are
dropping - but I'll just talk about
those when I do my next DC video so no
worries if you have any special requests
for videos next week for all the
trailers just let me know in the
comments below while you wait for
everything click here for that alternate
ending - Avengers end game where Iron
Man meets his daughter in the soul world
and click here for my Mandalorian
episode 4 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]